my turn-ons are like a great jawline and
a high FICO score I love it I love I
love no and it's not about that you have
money in the bank it's that you have
your stuff together to know what a FICO
score is it is definitely about the
responsibility about having your stuff
together like how is that not by the way
it probably wasn't attractive to me
before yeah I was like do you have
floppy hair and full of drama that's
actually what I really wanted now I want
the FICO score now I just want to know
you're fiscally responsible with
whatever you have or just responsible in
general are you like a citizen you know
a responsible citizen who here is turned
on by a good FICO score oh please
yes and you don't have to have a million
dollars we just need to be able to get a
mortgage honey that's it you know